the first time I saw Sidhu it was in a
small shop in the old town of Dubai I
just fell in love with this patterns so
I thought that it would look really
stunning to take something so Bedouin
and so heritage and make it so modern
[Music]
my name is Katia kofta knowledge I live
in Dubai and I'm a fashion designer and
working with Sidhu is my big passion
Sidhu was originally made by Bedouin
women in the desert they would weave
them for weeks and months but there are
still amazing artisans that make it by
hand so it's a very very complicated art
and it's actually an art that is
disappearing when you touch this fabric
you really feel it's so different it has
a soul
I always just set myself free and I do
whatever I want with fabric a lot of
inspiration comes from traveling from
living in different countries living in
London observing different cultures and
finding something that exists in one
culture and translating it into another
culture the most interesting thing about
this fabric is the stripes that you can
take the same color the same fabric and
reconstruct it in so many ways one
stripe can go horizontally one stripe
can go vertically one strike and go
across so you create a very different
movement on the body working and
creating in Dubai it's a truly unique
experience everything is coming up the
pop art the music so it's just pure calm
inspiration nothing stops me I can go
and buy fabrics at 1:00 a.m. I can
finish my photoshoot at 3:00 a.m. you
feel like anything you desire you can
accomplish the why is the city where the
world impossible doesn't exist I think
my project was to do is something global
I love to see women wearing it and being
complimented and feeling special and I
only see very beautiful interesting
future
[Music]